[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
60,18 voici les titres de ce jeudi 4
novembre
l'édifice millénaire va se refaire une
beauté l'église saint-martin de
sartrouville va être rénové deux ans de
travaux sont nécessaires pour
sauvegarder le lieu abîmé par les années
une convention a été signée récemment
entre la municipalité et la fondation du
patrimoine près d'un français sur deux
ne serait pas revenu dans les lieux
culturels depuis cet été c'est le
résultat d'une enquête commandée par le
gouvernement ait révélé il ya quelques
jours qu'en est-il dans les yvelines
nous prendrons le pot au ciné c'est ça
il en cours et au théâtre montansier à
versailles enfin la compétition fera son
retour l'an prochain après deux
annulations l'open de france de golf se
déroulera en septembre 2000 22 à saint
quentin en yvelines information
confirmée ce jeudi par la fédération
française la dotation du tournoi sera en
plus doublé
focus tout à l'heure également sur le
métier de restauratrice d'oeuvres d'art
un métier passion et nous avons
rencontré justement 5 restauratrice à
versailles
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres et
les suites de la sphère du bébé renversé
à poissy pour rappel le nourrisson de
quatre mois a été percuté lundi soir
dans sa poussette les faits se sont
produits au niveau d'un passage piéton
près de l'hôpital de la ville au
carrefour de l'avenue lyautey de
l'avenue est de la maladrerie le
chauffard à l'origine de l'accident a
été condamné à 18 mois de prison avec
sursis par le tribunal de versailles
annulations également de son permis de
conduire avec interdiction de le
repasser pendant un an sa voiture
confisquée l'homme avait d'abord pris la
fuite avant de se rendre à la police
quelques heures plus tard son permis
avait déjà été suspendue à plusieurs
reprises et une annulation également
pour son permis de conduire le petit
garçon lui va mieux il est sorti de
l'hôpital necker où la vérité a
transporté en urgence je vous en parlais
dans les titres l'église saint-martin de
sartrouville va être restauré il ya
quelques jours une convention en ce sens
a été signée entre la municipalité et la
fondation du patrimoine un partenariat
pour financer une partie du chantier est
de deux ans de travaux sont nécessaires
pour redonner un second souffle au
bâtiment abymes parle-t-on justin
brasier monument historique de plus de
mille ans d'âge l'église saint-martin de
sartrouville va se refaire une beauté
une convention était signée mercredi 20
octobre entre la mairie de sartrouville
et la fondation du patrimoine est l'acte
le lancement officiel d'une collecte
publique pour la reconstruction du
clocher un clocher particulier qui
nécessite d'être repris intégralement
c'est le seul clocher octogonal
d'île de france qui a été construit à
l'époque comme ça et donc il ya un
problème de joint entre l'ensemble des
pierres qui constitue là le clocher donc
il va falloir le démonter entièrement et
le remonter à l'identique donc c'est un
travail important dont un budget
important et la fondation du patrimoine
est à nos côtés on s'engage à partir de
cette convention à mettre les moyens de
la fondation pour faciliter cette
collecte la ronde optimale faire en
sorte qu' il y ait un maximum de duret
de dons qui arrivent pour permettre la
meilleure réflexion possible face à un
problème de sécurité le coup d'envoi de
deux ans de travaux sera donné début
novembre une restauration répartis en
trois phases la première va durer un an
c'est uniquement sur la partie est de
montres de l'église avec notamment la
flèche la reconstruction de la flèche à
partir du tambour ensuite la phase 2
c'est donc le reste des façades avec la
restauration complète des façades des
contreforts mais également de la
couverture et de la charge contre les
quatre derniers mois de travaux c'est la
phase 3 chez les travaux intérieurs avec
emplacement de parc est attaqué par la
vrillette et le renforcement et
l'extension de la tribune en vue de la
cession d'ing le plus gros des travaux
la reconstruction de la flèche à
l'identique historique vous avez déposé
toutes les pierres de la flèche et on va
garder les pierres qui sont sûres
les plus les plus saines en fait ça
certaines pierres qui sont détériorées
qui sont pour le moins de 10 cm
d'épaisseur dont celle là on vient dé
remplacées par de nouvelles pièces
montant des travaux 3 5 millions d'euros
et pour ces rénovations ils exercent des
métiers d'artisanat et de passion
ébéniste peintre tailleur tous ont à
coeur de transmettre un savoir-faire
primordial pour la sauvegarde du
patrimoine
céline charles est allé à la rencontre
de cinq restauratrice d'art à versailles
dorures encadrement restauration des
sculptures peintes ou encore de tableau
l'atelier du soleil à versailles assure
depuis bientôt 30 ans le suivi des
oeuvres dans le temps sur place elles
sont cinq à redonner vie à ces oeuvres
les deux gérantes ont repris la
structure il ya cinq ans nous avons
vocation de
de sauvegarder le patrimoine culturel et
de le faire traverser encore plus
à la fois sans les métiers de tradition
mais il faut faire attention de pas non
plus trop rester dans la tradition
puisque on doit avoir un certain recul
en fait en restauration on va utiliser
des produits qui sont facilement
réversible et s'est appliqué un mastic
faire des reprises de déchirures
dissoudre une couche de peinture ou
encore faire des retouches à la fois
historien scientifique artisans ce
métier pluridisciplinaire demande aux
restaurateurs plusieurs compétences on a
quand même une
une solide base tout ce qui est
matériaux constitutifs avec tout ce qui
l'histoire de l'art à la physique la
chimie jamais c'est un condensé de tout
ce que j'aimais faire scientifiques
artistiques manuelles voilà ça demande
aussi des connaissances en histoire de
l'art les formations sont sélectives
mais à la clé c'est un métier
passionnant et gratifiant qui est avant
tout au service des oeuvres ici
particuliers collectionneurs et musées
j'aime pousser les portes de l'atelier
quand des personnes nous apporte un
petit tableau qui pour eux représentent
avec quelque chose voilà c'est toute une
histoire dans leur famille et puis puis
nous apporte ça c'est vrai que bon il va
pas être en très bon état et puis nous
on leur envoie là
ont beau faire on est juste là pour
faire passer
les oeuvres à travers le temps et à
travers les âges donc
faut vraiment être respecté un maximum
mes oeuvres d'art un métier axée sur la
transmission pour que les oeuvres d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui puissent continuer à
vivre encore un peu demain lé français
beauty leurs lieux culturels c'est en
tout cas le résultat d'une enquête qui
le dit commandé par le gouvernement elle
révèle que près d'un français sur deux
ne serait pas retourner au cinéma ou
dans une salle de spectacle depuis cet
été qu'en est-il dans les yvelines nous
avons posé la question à geneviève
dichamp qui est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir grégory
le directrice du théâtre montansier à
versailles avant de vous laisser répond
nous sommes allés également prendre le
pouls du côté d'un cinéma c'est le ciné
7 à elancourt et c'est avec michael mier
d'euros
aussi mais cette d'elancourt la
fréquentation n'est toujours pas revenue
à la normale en cause la crise sanitaire
et l'instauration du pass sanitaire en
france le 21 juillet dernier
l'établissement classé art et essai a
perdu de nombreux spectateurs et
notamment un public familial sur ses
vacances de la toussaint moins 30 moins
35% là par exemple on a un bon
indicateur c'est des vacances de la
toussaint on est en plein dedans
les résultats sont pas du tout ce qu on
aurait pu espérer pour des vacances de
la toussaint normal parce qu'en général
ce sont des vacances comment dirais-je
ont fait le plein quoi l'ordre dans les
cinémas en tout cas et là on est on est
on est vraiment ça dépend des séances ça
dépend la programmation bien sûr tout ça
joue aussi beaucoup mais on sent bien
que les gens ont du mal à revenir les
signer cette d'elancourt va mieux depuis
la rentrée la fréquentation est passée
de moins de 60 % cet été à moins de 30%
cet automne mais les chiffres restent
historiquement bas pour cette salle
ouverte depuis 1975 dans le quartier 17
mar et les blockbusters de ces dernières
semaines n'ont pas booster sa
fréquentation le james bond par exemple
c'est un très bon indicateur on a fait
nous par exemple au ciné cette je dirais
à un peu plus la moitié de ce qu'on
aurait dû faire normalement en termes
d'entrées avec un film de ce calibre-là
surtout qu'il était quand même très
attendu bon c'est pas un james bond qui
va avoir une carrière la carrière qu'il
aurait dû avoir normalement avant le
début de la crise sanitaire en 2020 le
ciné c'est d'elancourt réalisé en
moyenne près de 110 mille entrées par an
donc une tendance qui se confirme donc
dans ce cinéma mais on va prendre
désormais un autre exemple celui du
théâtre montant versailles geneviève
dichamp codirectrice du théâtre est avec
nous par visioconférence en petite
précision sur l'étude dont je parlais
juste avant ce sujet elle a été menée
auprès de plus de 3000 personnes de plus
de 18 ans et réalisé entre le 31 août et
le 3 septembre donc la tendance a pu
évoluer depuis quand est-il au théâtre
montansier ce que vous avez noté vous de
votre côté une baisse de la
fréquentation
alors nous on note une baisse de la
fréquentation sur la saison sur le
lancement de l'édition de la saison mais
sur les premiers spectacles que nous
avons réalisés depuis septembre on a
fait de très belles salles alors on
constate d'abord plusieurs indicateurs
les gens se décident très tardivement
par exemple nous on joue le 31 décembre
d'habitude à cette date là on a vendu
400 places pour le 31 décembre cette
année nous en avons dû nous en avons
vendu seulement 100 pour le moment mais
si ça se trouve le 31 décembre nous
serons nous en montrent très belle salle
donc ça veut dire des gens ont changé
leurs habitudes des avis la temporalité
des habitudes qui ont changé on réserve
- à l'avant sont prend plutôt son billet
à la dernière minute c'est ça c'est
peut-être une tendance liée au fait qu'
on ne sait pas ce comment va évoluer
aussi cette épidémie est peut-être que
c'est aussi pour ça que ça freine les
spectateurs clairement il ya comment va
évoluer l'épidémie il souhaite pas faire
l'avancé encore de l'achat de billets
pour être annoncé dans quelques semaines
ou quelques mois donc effectivement ils
attendent mais nous on a constaté voilà
de belles salles on a eu des spectacles
effectivement et qui ont répondu à
l'attenté du public ensuite il ya un
deuxième constat qui peut être fait
c'est que les théâtres qui comme nous
font de la création font des séries et
de l'action culturelle sur le territoire
s'en sortent beaucoup mieux que ce
qu'ils font du data date
avec on va dire moins de travail en
direction du public et notamment des
scolaires j'allais justement vous poser
la question comment vous expliquez que
al'inverse d'autres lieux culturels le
théâtre montansier s'en sortent mieux
c'est peut-être la face on l'a projeté
différentes comment vous l'expliquez
alors nous on a une approche différente
puisque on fait de la création et on
fait des séries donc le bouche à oreille
aller de se faire dans versailles et
autour et puis on travaille aussi
beaucoup avec les scolaires et comme
vous le savez les scolaires n'étaient
pas tenus au pas salutaire sur les
matinées en journée matinée à 10h et à
14h donc on a aussi eu pas mal de
scolaires
donc oui selon la prog la programmation
qui est fait par les lieux évidemment le
retour du public est différent mais
comment ça s'est passé oui les
condamnons ces différents pendant
justement la période de fermeture du
théâtre comment ça s'est passé justement
avec le public au moment où vous avez
réussi à garder le lien avec votre
public pour qu'il soit fidèle justement
à la réouverture du théâtre alors non
les on a communiqué avec régulièrement
en leur donnant des nouvelles et des
spectacles qu'on était en train de
répéter même s'ils pouvaient pas les
voir on a été très scrupuleux sur les
remboursements de manière à pas donner
le sentiment aux spectateurs que ont
joué sur la tréso et puis on a eu de
très grosses actions sur le territoire
en direction des scolaires puisqu'on a
touché entre décembre et fin avril plus
de 10000 scolaire sur le territoire des
yvelines et donc ça évidemment ça a
certainement un impact aujourd'hui sur
le retour des spectateurs et autour de
vous avec les autres professionnels qui
vous avez pu échanger qu'en est -il est
ce que c'est assez inégal finalement il
ya des salles qui fonctionne bien des
d'autres salles qui ont du mal à attirer
le public qu'est ce que vous avez pu
constater il ya effectivement une grande
inégalité notamment dans paris intra
muros où c'est beaucoup plus difficile
qu'ailleurs par exemple sauf un ou deux
spectacles qui fonctionne très bien
et on constate en tout cas tout ce que
la temporalité et avariés et que là où
des gens prenait l'envié y ait deux mois
trois mois quatre mois al avance
aujourd'hui les prennent à 15 jours ou à
dix jours que l'une des change
complètement la gestion de la salle où
il ne s'est pas à quelques jours si on
sera 300-400 savent donc sa chance sur
le plan des ouvreuses sur le plan de
l'organisation du bas ça nous oblige à
nous organiser complètement différemment
de ce que nous faisions les saisons
précédentes est ce qu'à votre avis eu un
effet pas sanitaire qui peut expliquer
peut-être cette fuite des spectateurs au
niveau national
clairement oui nous on a eu un certain
nombre de mails et un certain nombre de
courriers dans lesquels les spectateurs
nous disait qu'il ne reviendrait pas
tant qu'il y aurait un pass sanitaire
donc clairement ça n'est pas une aide
nous on a maintenu le masque à
l'intérieur de la salle puisque c'est au
choix des directeurs il nous a semblé
plus que rassurant pour les spectateurs
que le masque soit maintenue mais
clairement la contrôle du pass est pas
mal vécue par certains spectateurs bien
vécue par d'autres mais c'est clairement
pour certains un frein en plus
inquiétants 30% des personnes
interrogées par l'anc est cité tout à
l'heure affirme que leur fréquentation
des lieux culturels serait probablement
moindre qu'avant la pandémie est ce que
vous êtes inquiète pour les prochaines
semaines ce que les perspectives sont
bonnes et ce que vous vous êtes plutôt
inquiète
alors jeu j'essaye de ne pas être trop
peu inquiète mais c'est vrai que il faut
pas trop lire les actualités sur le
coded sinon
pour les théâtres ça devient ça devient
tout de suite inquiétant
moi j'ai effectivement si je prends
l'état de billetterie jusqu'au 30 juin
je peux être inquiète parce que on est
très très en dessous de l'état on était
haut à la même date en 2019 mais si je
me réfère au premier spectacle j'espère
que le public va revenir au fur et à
mesure des spectacles ce qu'il faudrait
pas c'est qu'il y ait dans les semaines
qui viennent un nouveau coup d'arrêt ou
alors des contraintes sanitaires
beaucoup plus lourde que ce qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui et qu'il a vraiment
serait dramatique pour le secteur donc
l'éviter nouvelles contraintes et que
faudrait-il faire à votre avis pour
relancer la machine peut être davantage
de soutien au monde culturel à hautmont
de la programmation culturelle bat
surtout il faudrait arrêter de dire que
les salles de théâtre c'est des lieux
dangereux c'est ce qu'on a entendu
pendant 18 mois que toutes les salles
fermées étaient des lieux très dangereux
et ça ne peut pas ne pas avoir laissé de
traces dans la tête d'un certain nombre
de spectateurs
ne sont pas des lieux dangereux le
message est passé une seconde étude jeu
précis sera réalisé en décembre par le
ministère de la culture elle a été
commandée pour voir un signe justement
cette tendance se poursuit on l'a
compris une tendance finalement assez
inégal selon les culturel merci
geneviève dichamp d'avoir été avec nous
la green town codirectrice du théâtre
montansier c'est à versailles
[Musique]
du sport également dans l'actualité avec
cette bonne nouvelle pour les amateurs
de golf l'open de france sera de retour
en 2022 au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'information
a été confirmée ce jeudi par la
fédération française de golf et
l'european tour le rendez vous avait été
annulé ces deux dernières années
pandémie de colis de 19 oblige le
tournoi se disputera du 22 au 25
septembre 2022 et aura une dotation de 3
millions d'euros le double de la
dernière édition ce qui pourrait attirer
des joueurs de renom écouter ses propos
recueillis par mickaël millero
c'est un travail d'équipé
comme vous savez c'est très important
pour la fédération française de golf de
faire revenir l'open de france au
calendrier nous avons une super dates en
septembre
le soldat s'est aussi à la malade que
nous avons eu l'honneur d'accueillir la
ryder cup en 2018
l'open de france de retour en septembre
2022 au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines et du rugby à présent avec
le quinze de france féminin qui sera
engagé samedi dans la première journée
de la tournée d'automne abane match
contre l'afrique du sud pour ce duel
yvelinoise emilie boulard fait partie de
la liste des titulaires dévoilé ce jeudi
par le staff tricolore à l'arrière de 22
ans honorera face aux springboks sa
quatrième sélection avec les bleus après
des rencontres contre l'angleterre
l'irlande et le pays de galles au
dernier tournoi des six nations
le coc u19 vous l'avez compris et vous
l'avez vu dans le journal a eu des
conséquences sur le monde culturel le
monde sportif conséquence également sur
les mariages leur nombre a diminué de
34% en 2020 et après deux années
compliquées pour les professionnels les
célébrations sont repartis à la hausse
cette année est les 13 et 14 novembre un
salon du mariage se tient à massy en
essonne et une yvelinoise sera présente
elles portent beaucoup d'espoirs pour la
saison 2010 22 mélanie poké une robe
fleurie pour un instant solennel flora
fait partie des modèles proposés par
laurence mercier cette créatrice
installée à chevreuse créé depuis un an
et demi pour les futurs mariés c'est moi
à regarder et ça fait rêver c'est la
robe d'un jour c'est
puis ça référent la personnalité de la
mariée quoi donc
c'est aussi ça qui me plaît c'est une
demande unique et c'est une robe unique
d'un jour si laurence mercier n'a pas
été touché par la crise pour maternité
elles placent beaucoup d'espoir dans la
saison 2022 en 2020 seulement cent
cinquante cinq mariages ont été célébrés
ses 34 % de moins qu'en 2019 j'ai été
obligé de fermer cause des confinement
est en fait à partir de demi
mimi mais je crois qu'on a pu réouvrir
alors là si je suis passé de zéro à
surcharger il ya une grosse demande en
très peu de temps parce que du coup les
gens ont fini par savoir que leur
mariage était maintenu et on a aussi
senti que même les invités pas forcément
les mariés et de l'entourage proche il
avait vraiment envie de se faire plaisir
création sur base de modèles réalisation
sur mesures comptez entre 1000 et 2500
euros la robe laurence sera présente au
salon du mariage et de la réception de
massy en essonne
avant de refermer ce journal retour sur
cet événement qui se déroulait le
week-end dernier aux mureaux la ville
organisait une animation autour de la
bande dessinée au programme expositions
concours de cosplay stand de maquillage
ou encore rencontre avec des
dessinateurs le reportage de mathilde de
franco et bixente mairie ressenti steban
c'est au coeur de la rue paul doumer que
petits et grands se sont rassemblés pour
profiter des animations autour de la
bande dessinée tout au long de l'après
midi les fans de cosplay ont défilé dans
leurs plus beaux déguisements devant un
jury composé de trois personnes je suis
un bel paysanne de la belle et la bête
va après gagne ou pas quand on fait ça
surtout pour s'amuser de manière
générale les plus jeunes pouvaient
également se rendre sur des stands de
maquillage ou assister à un atelier de
dessin avec françois plisson dessinateur
de bandes dessinées il se prête au jeu
et
ils sont bien contents c'est un
troisième petit groupe que j'ai depuis
tout à l'heure ça se passe très bien
tout le monde sait à peu près dessiner
mais tout le monde ne sait pas en fait
si on s'entraîne ça fonctionne c'est
comme le piano violon pour fo trop
pratique et quoi des msa pour
l'événement une partie de la rue paul
doumer était piétonniser une
expérimentation qui vise à redynamiser
le centre ville des mureaux ça s'inscrit
dans tout un programme qu'on lance
sureau 2022 ou tous les deux mois la rue
sera piétonnisée avec différents
événements donc cette fois c'est au tour
de la bd mais y aura la fête de la
musique il y aura le marché de noël et
puis d'autres événements qui vont venir
et ce à tous les deux mois c'est une
expérimentation
l'idée c'est de voir sur 2023 ce qu'on
fait en termes de piétonnisation est ce
qu on a une piétonnisation permanente
par exemple le week-end et ce qu'on
reste sur une quête anisation assez
régulière mais toujours coupées avec des
événements voilà c'est vraiment en cause
itation chez lui un projet sur le long
terme qui démarre plutôt bien car malgré
la pluie les amateurs de la bande
dessinée et du causse mais était au
rendez vous voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité demain
vendredi vous avez rendez vous avec le
7-8 week-end de l'actualité mais aussi
des idées de sorties pour bien terminer
la semaine dans les yvelines belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]